quand t'es pas sage qu'est ce qu'on fait
doni fait c'est non on fait une punition
je procède au cas où vous pouviez de
déchets d'amiante et c'est vrai qu'ils
te donne tu essaies tu sais tout ça
facilement quand tu auras les enfants
qu'est ce que je leur ferai à toi tu
vois pas pardonné si c'est un tué quand
les parents ne sont pas sont durs avec
toi tu trouve qu'ils ont raison qu'ils
ont tort machete ça dépend des fois je
trouve qu'ils entendent des fonctions
qu'ils ont raison des faits c'est
comment
[Musique]
et
tu es contre ou pour la fessée toi
contre quand tu pleures pas tant des
fessées j'essaye des peuples oreilles
est ce que tu penses que des parents
raison qu'ils ont tort dans cette année
fait c'est qu'ils ont tort on punit de
sortir de sortir de quoi d'aller d'aller
au luxembourg par exemple
non mais je suis déjà me donne jamais
cessé non pas de juifs n'ont rien du
tout on tremble jamais tu vois pas comme
toi comment tu devrais pas content from
non qu'est ce que tu fais ça le faisait
je sais pas je me débats retrait et toi
aussi je les enfants jeux lors qu'est ce
que tu fais je présente pas j'avertis
non ils font ce qu'ils veulent tu crois
ça ouais bah ça dépend peut-être qu'ils
deviendront gâtés à force on dispute
c'est top
on tape jamais qu'est-ce qui se dispute
on va voir demain banques ou les deux ça
dépend des jours ça s'arrête souvent de
passage n'ont pas souvent c'est plutôt
sage en mousse mais j'avais dit j'avais
fait ça
alors ça une rame rarement qu'est ce que
tu fais quand ça arrive mon plan c'est
toi ben on tape tape ou dans les faits
cela l'accord là ça se fait volte face à
des bancs en d'abord ça fait mal quand
ça va quand même pas faire ça va tu
pleures quelquefois quand tu passage à
la maison qu'est ce qu'on fait ou à ses
dépens oui mais ça dépend pas de moi
alors bas à la figure ça lui joue sur
l'effet ceux ci n'ont jamais et comment
tu réagis quand on donne des tapes comme
ça car j'attends d'en face et on donne
quoi fait ça en fait c'est une grosse
fessée
et qu'est ce que tu fais toi maman
arbres à cache cache et quand tu auras
les enfants de durban en effet c'est toi
alors les bagarres ah bon tu bagarre à
tes enfants
non mais les enfants à toi quand il sera
plus grand ah oui quand j'ai un petit
frère mais quand tu vois les enfants à
toi quand tu seras pas pas toi-même
qu'est ce que tu feras dû l'entendre
effet c'était un jeu sera un méchant pas
non allez salut cowboys
[Musique]